that's a family tree get me to the nut
homie I'm at the roots I'm stretching
around
was that 1.5 million
and birth is coming in
[Music]
I'm Steve fear I'm here to answer the
internet let's let it rip would you jerk
LeBron off for all of his Athletics I
would suck LeBron off I would toss a
salad let him I'll get my tongue so far
you hear my voice coming out of his
mouth would I jerk LeBron up that's my
baby daddy come here LeBron just hit the
scoring title about to be there with you
baby boy
would you rather be filthy rich in 1900
or poor now filthy rich in 1900 I would
have had a lot of people working for me
for free let me redo that one
again so I would be rich in 1900 you see
in New York Fury Street that's what I'd
be I'd be in the [__] railroads as a
conductor [__] being poor now I've been
pulled poor for too long if you could
have an endless supply of anything what
would it be yeah I would go if it's not
money I would go something weird like
cocaine like if I had an unlimited side
of cocaine like magic came to my my oh
and like hey stay Furious here but every
night you can go underneath the table a
ball for you
[Music]
I'm about to be
hello baby
or desserts for life big facts dessert
boy come over here with your Swedish
[__] I am big on cakes pies ice creams
appetizers
you know it's like an opening act most
of the time you're like wasn't that good
didn't need I am an opening act so it
does hurt a little bit when I say that
but but as sometimes
please keep hiring me Hollywood as an
opening act
but definitely desserts oh fire you know
what you already had the closer a steak
and someone brings out a [__]
chocolate
molten cake I cut it open it's a magic
trick son
no one's got magic tricks that an
appetizer the [__] Bang Bang Shrimp
get the [__] out my face I got a bone
cake dog
dessert all right how many times can you
eat the same meal before you get sick on
it this is a funny ass Story one time I
ate sushi every day for about a month
and I got iodine poisoning and no
mercury poisoning because the [__]
salmon it was worth it I'll put I'll
pull that one back
too gotta go away for a little bit I got
murdered no mine was real it was the uh
it was powerful what happens you get
really sick you should watch out for
that it's not a deal I thought I had
cancer and they're like you got mercury
poison I was like ah no from Sushi yes
baller [__] it's like gout Burger poison
is like gout you get that [__] you're
doing well you know what I mean no one
gets gout in the poor yeah ain't no one
gets gallon they're poor you're gonna do
a well you're a lighthouse
is he
would you accept a million dollars to be
deported from the U.S you can never come
back but you get to take one person I'm
out homie I'm in Mexico I'm the new
cartel Steve Fury called the Golfo I got
my fine ass girlfriend uh no I'm I'm
Adam America you know it's so [__] I've
it's so [__] up right now but you're
gonna see me in Portugal smoking hash
with my girlfriend maybe doing some
heroin it's gonna be nice just give me
nothing it's gonna be real good if you
got a one-time pass to do whatever you
wanted what crime would you commit bank
robbery you and the Bros you know what I
mean bank robbery is the only one where
you get the homies to come in you know I
mean I murder someone that's all by
myself how fun is that bank robbery
someone's got a gun my other girl he's
got the car yeah
someone's in the safe yeah I'm coming in
get the [__] down
20 20 racks in my bank account bank
attack no every day yes the bank account
you know I'm like like when I have a
good night out I'm like damn you were
kissing that girl you kind of fingered
that chick in the thing imagine a bank
account was like you shot an old woman
Jeff that was [__] incredible I'm out
there smashing in the 442 getting out of
there just running around downtown like
it's Heat
all day it's homies all day all my boys
we robbing banks is out here homie would
you rather awake to a [__] or a
hundred dollars under your pillow every
morning big facts gotta say who's given
the [__] because I've gotten a lot of
seven dollar blow jobs
if I could wake up
with a bank account I'm getting Sean
every
blow jobs you know what I mean there's a
lot of bad [__] eating
would rather eat lunch and get my bad
blood job though if it's good head
I don't need water dog if it's good
ahead I'll live off that I'll die a slow
complete death suck everything out my
body the soul went on to The Ether
by the end we were so dehydrated
this is the internet just come like
[__] gum
it's disgusting what yeah be careful
Jesus Christ if you could wipe one group
of people off this Earth who would it be
all right a little funky there I would
go white BMW drivers if I could pull up
with one gun and a bullet that only
killed Wayne BMW I'd be on Santa Monica
in California
just every stop light they're gone
they're out dog I bid you would do homie
that sounds like you're doing the world
of service I'm doing well ain't no
you've never you've never seen a white
BMW and was like that guy was cool man
that was we just hang out one time
all right would you rather be naked all
the time or have everyone clothed at a
time I'm a layer boy okay what I'm
saying I got a jacket I got a t-shirt I
got a wife beater I got a girdle
I'm here for layers dog I ain't working
out enough for us to be naked the only
thing that keeps me allowed to [__] is
that I'm funny and I got a shell above
me so
we on that if I was gay for a day who
would I bang Tom [__] Hardy he's
manly but he's also a little a little
more little than me he's a wheat yeah
he's like five six he's a wee little
fellas so he would be on the bottom but
he'd be looking back I'm like [__]
Tom Hardy dog what's good
those eyes oh and he's like wrestling he
does Jujitsu and also yeah Tom Hardy
would you bang your cousin to win the
Powerball listen my family is Irish and
Italian so everyone's fine and we got
that we got that blue collar thing we're
like we look like we work out but we
just got day jobs
so I'm [__] one of my family members for
sure yo I'm not gonna say who but I
think she knows she knows
we played Doctor a little bit too much
girl you know like oh you got
[Laughter]
oh Christmas will never be the same yeah
billion 103. I [__] my mom for a
billion dollars
that's a family tree get me to the nut
homie I'm at the roots I'm stretching
around
was that 1.5 million
and birth is coming in oh what is this I
thought she said full grown white versus
a polar bear I'm like wow I'm like damn
bars goes wild these days really push
into the agenda all right a full-grown
great white versus a full-grown polar
bear in an olympic-side swimming pool
that is seven feet deep and 75 degrees
Fahrenheit who wins you know Paul Gray
mice get [__] up by killer whales you
know I mean no one's touching a polar
bear thank you polar bear's walking
around polar bear just got to do this
game over son you've never even seen
different different spaces sizes bam
yeah it's got eaten I mean killer whale
is [__] Sea World doc no one's
domesticating polar bears polar bears
don't mama I drank too many beers
[Music]
that last one got me
thank you so much
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out